So last week we already discussed the story of
Republican Senator from Texas Ted Cruz fleeing
the United States from Mexico with his family
when power outages and major storms hit Texas.
And Ted Cruz, who formally voted against hurricane
relief funding for Hurricane Sandy in New York and
New Jersey, wanted immediate emergency funding for
what happened in Texas. He asked for that funding
hypocritically and then fled to Cancun, Mexico,
to go to the beach. Now, because of the uproar
that it caused, he cut his trip short and flew
back to Texas not even 24 hours later. And there
are endless calls for him to resign. And you just
have to see how Fox News covered it to understand
how these reactionary right wingers end up in
seemingly alternate universes. Imaginary alternate
universe is I think it's important to say it was
a combination of pretending it wasn't happening.
What about ISM and pretending that it's just no
big deal? So let's look at some examples here.
First, here is Fox and Friends defending Ted Cruz
and saying, yeah, but what about Andrew Cuomo?
Fifty five seconds. And by the way, Chris Cuomo,
who was allowed to interview his brother in
times of good back in the old, is not allowed
anymore. He's calling on Ted Cruz to resign.
Right. And yet not a word about his brother who's
who's who's got the scandal on his hands. It is
an amazing double standard. It exposes exactly
who they are, the PR department of the Democrat
Party. They're going after Ted Cruz because
he's been an effective, consistent conservative
for years. He may have made the wrong call.
He acknowledges that. But the media, well,
they they show who they are every time. It does
look a little lopsided over on ABC. All right.
I don't even know why Steve Doocy is talking about
ABC there. Maybe it looks to me like Pete Hegseth
was attacking CNN. Maybe I missed something
earlier about ABC. I'm not sure. But of course,
the playbook is Ted Cruz did something completely
indefensible and pathetic and humiliating. Well,
attack the media, attack CNN. Attack Andrew
Cuomo. Attack Chris Cuomo. Hold on. This is about
Ted Cruz. Why are we talking about those other
people? Other approaches included coming up with
long forgotten scandals to resuscitate.
Like, for example, they went back to Hillary.
They put up a headline on Fox News about, quote,
media and political elite mock Trump supporters
with a picture of Hillary Clinton from
a speech she gave in New York City
five years ago in 2016. This is not a joke. They
actually covered that as the Ted Cruz scandal was
on fire. It reminds me of the scene from the movie
The Naked Gun, where the great Leslie Nielsen
is saying nothing to see here. Please disperse
as a building is exploding behind him. That's
actually what they were covering as everybody
else was covering the disgusting disaster of
the absence, literal absence from country of Texas
leadership during their storms and power outages.
And then while every network was continuing to
cover what was going on in Texas and what was
going on with Ted Cruz, Fox News decided to run
an explosive story about Bill de Blasio, the New
York City mayor supporting outdoor, socially
distanced dance performances in New York City
during the pandemic. OK, so that's Fox News's
coverage of Ted Cruz on Fox News. Now, understand
that some other networks and some other right wing
shows and other right wing media outlets, they
didn't even talk about it at all. Fox and Friends
went in on defending what Ted Cruz was doing.
That's one approach. But there were many who
were just talking about other things. They
were talking about, you know, Joe Biden and his
dog, which we will get to a little bit later,
and all sorts of other non stories. And we are
seeing it before our very eyes in real time,
the sort of fermentation of germination of maybe
what is likely to be the approach from right
wing media for the next four years. And we've
predicted it. We weren't unique in predicting
it that right wing media was. Going to be
particularly crazy and weaponized in part because
you have more competition right now in this right
wing media space than you had four years ago,
for who can do the most cartoonish, crazy coverage
to get away from criticizing anything the right
does or to find new ways to criticize anything Joe
Biden does. And we are seeing it and we're going
to have some more examples a little bit later.
But let's now get to an incredible interview
that Ted Cruz gave to Sean Hannity,
and that's what I want to discuss next.